so we have two different molecules here
this is hydrogen peroxide we call it
peroxide because it has this oxygen
oxygen bond and here we have oxygen
difluoride where oxygen is bonded to two
different fluorines and what I want you
to do is pause this video use this
periodic table of elements I have here
and this is more than just a typical
information a periodic table of elements
it also gives you the
electronegativities of these different
elements and these electronegativities
are based on the Pauling scale named
after famous biologist and chemist Linus
Pauling and so using the information
here and what you know already about
oxidation states think about the
oxidation states or the oxidation
numbers for each of the Constituent
elements in these molecules so pause the
video now so I'm assuming you have given
a shot at it and you might have
immediately realized that something very
interesting is going on we've said in
the past that oxygen typically oxygen
typically because it's two valence
electrons away from a from a full
valence shell because it is so
electronegative oxygen typically takes
electrons from other things typically
two electrons which typically gives it
an oxidation state of negative and
oxidation number or oxidation state of
negative two this is so electronegative
and it so typically oxidizes other
things that we've called the whole
phenomenon oxidation but what's
interesting here is that oxygen isn't
purely bonded of things less and negret
less electronegative than itself and the
hydrogen peroxide yes it is bonded to
the hydrogen but it's also bonded to
another oxygen obviously these two are
going to be equally electronegative so
what would be the oxidation states or
the oxidation numbers here well hydrogen
once again we pretend hydrogen because
it's less electronegative it would have
a partially positive charge because the
electrons would spend more time around
this oxygen but when we're talking about
oxidation states we don't like this
partial charge business we want to
pretend like these covalent bonds or
ionic bonds hypothetical ionic bonds and
if they were hypothetically ionic bonds
what would happen well if you had to
give these electrons to somebody you
would give them to the oxygen
trends in this period give them to the
oxygen giving it an oxidation state of
negative one with the hydrogen having
these electrons taken away it's going to
have an oxidation state of positive one
and the same thing is going to be true
for that oxygen and that hydrogen right
over there so this is fascinating
because this is an example where oxygen
has an oxidation state not of negative
two but of negative an oxidation state
of negative one so this is already kind
of interesting now it gets even more
interesting when we go to oxygen
difluoride why is this more interesting
because fluorine is the one thing on
this entire table that is more
electronegative than oxygen so in our
hypothetical this is a covalent bond but
in our hypothetical ionic bond if we had
to give these electrons to one of these
atoms you would give it to the floor II
so the fluorine each of them would have
an oxidation state of negative one and
the oxygen here now you can imagine this
is nuts for oxygen the oxidation state
for oxygen it's giving up these
electrons it would be it would be a
positive two and we talked about
oxidation states when we write this
little superscript here we write the
sign after the number and that's just
the convention it has an oxidation state
of positive two oxygen the thing that
likes to oxidize other things it itself
has been oxidized by fluorine so this is
a this is a pretty dramatic example of
how something might stray from what's
typical oxidation state or it's typical
oxidation number and in general oxygen
will have an oxidation state or
oxidation number in most in most
molecules of negative two but unless
it's bonded with another oxygen or it's
bonded to fluorine where it has which is
a much more electronegative and we're
actually not much more but a is it's the
only atom that is more electronegative
than or the only element that is more
electronegative than oxygen